So, how do we find the correct values of theta to minimize our
cost function J of big theta?
We'll use a search algorithm that takes some initial guesswork data, and
iteratively changes theta, so that J of theta keeps on getting smalle,r until it
converges on some minimum value.
The algorithm we're going to discuss, is called gradient descent.
Here's a one-dimensional depiction of what gradient descent might look like.
We have some starting point where J of theta is large, and we continue to
try new values of theta, and J of theta keeps on getting smaller and smaller.
Until we arrive here, the final value.
This theta value gives us our smallest value of J of theta.
And so, we know that we've minimized J of theta.
This is what gradient descent might look like in one dimension.
Let's see what it looks like in two dimensions.
Here again we see that we start with some high value of J of theta.
And we continue to iteratively update theta one and
theta two until we arrive here.
The global minimum of J of big theta.
Gradient descent updates the values of theta,
according to the following equation, Theta n is equal to theta n itself,
minus alpha, times d, d theta n, J of big theta.
Note the derivative here, d, d theta n of J of theta.
If you're less familiar with calculus, this is calculating the rate of change of
J, with respect to this particular theta n.
So, if we change this theta n a little bit, how much does J of big theta change?
We simultaneously perform this update for every theta n, in our big theta.
That is, every single theta n in the entire set of thetas.
The alpha in this equation,
is a parameter of the algorithm called the learning rate.
What we're essentially saying here is that,
in the space of all possible values of theta, what's the smallest step I
can make in a certain direction, such that I'll make the value of J smaller?
So, each time I do this,
I'm taking one of these small steps towards the minimum value of J of theta.
I'm not going to go into the calculus here, but
based of the cost function J's dependence on the various theta n's,
if we actually perform this differentiation.
The actual equation that we'll use to update our theta n values is this.
Theta n equals theta n minus alpha,
times the sum from i equals 1 to m, of y predicted of x i.
Minus y observed x i time x sub n i.
You may be wondering how we set a value of the learning parameter, alpha.
A regress discussion is beyond the scope of this course.
However, the important thing to note is that the smaller learning rate,
will cause the algorithm to take longer to converge on the optimal theta values.
Since you're taking smaller and smaller steps down the curve.
Larger values of alpha, can converge more quickly.
But they're more prone to skip over the cost function's known value.
This can cause J to increase, rather than decrease monotonically.
The best way to make sure that your alpha is suitable, is simply to
keep track of the cost functions value as you iteratively update it, and
make sure it's always going down.
If not, you learning rate is probably too high.